welcome back everybody we're Switching
gears to Waupaca County Wisconsin where
trial kicked off this week for defendant
William zielinski he's charged with
killing his girlfriend's son while
confronting him for stealing expensive
reptiles you see zielinski sold exotic
animals through his business Wild Bill's
Exotics prosecutors say in 2020
zielinski had guns alcohol and more than
25 thousand dollars worth of reptiles
stolen from his property those reptiles
included a seventeen thousand dollar
lizard a seven thousand dollar python
along with a crocodile and boa
constrictor zielinski was reportedly
given a tip pointing to his girlfriend's
18 year old son Riley Minette Powell as
well as 20 year old Ashton Toady as the
suspects the defendant called 9-1-1 and
told police that he confronted Minette
Powell and shot him after an alleged
attack zielinski's girlfriend Tiffany
Powell was with zielinski during the
confrontation doorbell video footage
reportedly shows Powell pointing a gun
at her own son and then returning it to
zielinski before the Fatal shot was
fired Powell pleaded guilty to
first-degree reckless endangerment and
felony firearms possession she was
sentenced to 15 years in prison
zielinski is pleading not guilty to his
murder charge and faces life in prison
if convicted on Monday opening
statements were presented to the jury
here's how both sides argued their case
Tiffany Powell's going to testify we
brought her from prison too
and she's going to testify that Riley
never touched the gun he didn't reach
for the gun that he went at bill with
his fists but when you press a gun
hard
against somebody's armpit
and you pull the trigger
on a double-barreled 12-gauge shotgun
that's going to kill somebody or it's
practically certain to kill somebody and
what happened on October 19th of 2020
wasn't a vicious intentional crime
it was an accident
a tragic accident
caused when Riley grabbed the shotgun
from Bill and try to pull it at himself
away from Bill
an accident
during court this week the jury saw ring
doorbell footage of the confrontation
between the victim the defendant and
Powell here's what it captured right
before the Fatal shot
thank you
again
[Music]
Brian let's break that down for a second
because the ring camera it only shows
the moments before and after the
shooting how is that going to help or
hurt either case so Jesse it creates a
narrative of course you're missing the
perfect block when the shot goes off but
seeing what's going on before hearing
the Put it Down fight like a man but
it's two on one I think both sides can
use that argument to their advantage one
saying hey this is ordinary Force they
are promising only to use their fists to
fight why is he then using deadly force
but one can argue two against one could
they kill him if he doesn't take the
shotgun I think both sides can use her
advantage and what happens before and
after creates a very strong narrative
even though you're missing a piece maybe
someone takes a stand and testifies that
missing piece it's kind of like that
rain example in law school and they're
like you might not see the rain but if
it's see water on the ground you see
people holding umbrella you can assume
it was raining so Dave you know
accidents happen crimes committed is
that a better defense than self-defense
I think he's doing a combination which
means he's gonna have to take the stand
on his own defense and by the way he's
in a wheelchair now the defendant which
will get some jury appeal but the
crucial witness here is going to be the
victim's mother the defendant's
girlfriend who took the defendant's side
and all this until now now she's sitting
in a prison cell cut a deal with
prosecutors she's going to testify I
assume on behalf of the prosecution to
say that no this was not self-defense
that Riley her son was not grabbing at
the gun so that would undermine not just
self-defense but also accidents so if
her testimony is compelling then it's a
good day for the prosecutors all right
yeah these kind of cases they are also
kind of tough to predict as well we'll
continue to monitor it here on the long
crime daily and speaking of coming up on
Long crime daily a gas station owner is
facing a murder charge in the death of a
South Carolina teen last month while his
mother is demanding the arrest of a
second suspect we're finishing Today's
Show in Richland County South Carolina
where a mother is demanding a second
arrest in the death of her teenage son
he was shot and killed at a gas station
last month after being falsely accused
of shoplifting Shell gas station owner
Rick Chao is facing a murder charge
after shooting and killing 14-year-old
Cyrus Carmack Belton in May authorities
say that the defendant and his son Andy
Chow apparently believed that the teen
was trying to steal water bottles from
the convenience store the father and son
had an argument with the victim before
inside the store before Andy Chow chased
him outside the defendant joined the
chase armed with a pistol and Andy Chow
reportedly said that Carmack Belton had
a gun and that is when the defendant
shot the victim in the back while he was
no longer on the store's property the
victim's mother posted on Facebook over
the weekend asking police to charge the
defendant's son with Murder She cited
Andy Chow's role in the attack because
he initiated the chase out of the store
while authorities do believe the victim
was armed during the incident the police
chief held a press conference explaining
why the incident was not self-defense
father shot the young man in the back
he was not laying on the ground
he was not did not have his hands up
let's even if he had shoplifted four
bottles of water which is what he
initially took out of the cooler and
then he put him back even if it had done
that that's not
that's not something you shoot anybody
over much less a 14 year old but you
just don't do that
you know
this location has had lots of incidents
in the past shoplifting incidents I've
been confrontations between the owners
of the store and
and customers and people in there
actually shoplifting
but
you don't do what
happened last night what cloud of the
issue is that the victim didn't have a
gun there was
that there was a confrontation we had to
make sure that those who fired the shots
did not have that gun pointed at them
and they did not
you know in the legal terms being feared
their life
and they shot he shot Rick trial shot
this young man in the back and he killed
him
Dave I get the mother's anger here
clearly but I want to talk the law is
there any legal theory that indicts the
Sun for murder or maybe any other charge
if he's not the one who pulled the
trigger
it has to be involved in this like for
example you'd have to commit a crime
like in the Ahmad Arbury case where he
impeded the victim's ability to run away
which is not present here he just chased
after him along with his father and he
yelled out gun and the victim did have a
gun and then the father shot him so
according to these facts you can't
charge the son which is why the
prosecutors are not charging him now if
he had done more if he was part of a of
an effort to do something illegal like
shoot him in the back that's different
if he said shoot him in the back then he
would go down with his father but he
didn't do any of those things so don't
expect criminal charges to be filed
against
you mentioned Ahmad Arbury so let's talk
about it Brian you were in Georgia for
the Ahmad Arbury trial great reporting
by the way and a father a son neighbor
the three of them they were all charged
but only one of them pulled that trigger
Travis McDaniel so does this case show
any similarities to what we saw with the
mod arbory out of 30 000 foot level yes
Father and Son chasing someone they
believed to have committed a crime and
the case of Ahmad Arbor is trespassing
and here it's it's theft and both then
we see that no crime was actually
committed or at least no felony was
committed and but that's where the
similarities stop to to Dave's point it
was the extent at which Ahmad arboret
was corralled and pushed from one block
to the next block the words that were
thrown at him uh the the actions that
were taken by all three to push him or
entrap him in an area where the murder
could happen now do we have all of the
facts as to what the sun did all we've
got here is he started the Chase and he
said gun Dave said he didn't say there's
the gun go and shoot him in the back and
so we're talking about in order to get
charges uh like they did in the yamad
arbor case did you encourage or promote
or push the commission of a crime that
doesn't seem to happen here yet so I
don't think there'll be charges yeah
it's always very fact specific and
that's important under the law Dave
Bryan thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here along
crime daily we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America